es geschah am dienstag in dieser
gesamtschule in lünen in nordrhein
westfalen
ein schüler wurde getötet und die
polizei hat einen mitschüler
festgenommen
der tatverdächtige 15 jährige wurde am
morgen in gewahrsam genommen
die staatsanwaltschaft und polizei in
dortmund mitteilten
die ermittler gehen nach ersten
erkenntnissen nicht von einem amoklauf
aus die sprecherin der polizei dortmund
da nase kita sagte natürlich für alle
nacht nachvollziehbar ein sehr
schwerwiegendes delikt nur jemand hat
einen anderen menschen getötet
ich denke viele schüler waren ja auch in
aufruhr daraufhin aus polizeilicher
sicht ist es wichtig dass dann natürlich
die spuren gesichert werden akribische
spurensicherung da stattfindet
vernehmungen zeugenbefragung stattfinden
aber natürlich auch was hier ganz
wichtig ist natürlich die betreuung der
schülerinnen und schüler viele
seelsorger waren hier um eben auch die
möglicher weise emotional aufgewühlten
dann zu betreuen und hier unterstützung
zu bieten
der getötete junge war 14 jahre alt eine
mordkommission übernahm die ermittlungen
der tatverdächtige sollte vernommen
werden laut polizei sind opfer und
tatverdächtiger deutsche
staatsangehörige der tatverdächtige der
in deutschland geboren sei verfüge
zusätzlich auch noch über die
kasachische staatsbürgerschaft